some of us just not you can't be friends
with people you don't agree I mean Nick
DiPaolo disagree with like 75% of shit I
love the guy I always love hanging out
with him we've known him forever I never
never like never do I say gods Nick
again I love it when he gets mad about
shit damn well you don't know what
fucking Obama dick yeah it's great he's
on that a cameo website you could just
pay him to trash your liberal friends
oh that's it's so fucking funny he'll
just like it was like what do you like
fucking Hillary you fucking faggot is in
his kitchen yeah it's fucking great wife
beater on yeah but look Patrice you know
I remember I I watch my son my son's
mother was in labor for 30 hours fucking
crazy long labor overnight over the next
morning she's like lying down he's like
in the little fucking another room or
whatever I'm watching like a fan-made
Patrice O'Neal documentary and he's just
saying like the most heinous shit about
how women aren't shit and about how
fucking bitch she needs you and but and
I just watched my son's mother push my
son out of her for 30 hours it was
fucking I mean the whole experience was
so mind-blowing and in my mind I'm going
I could never in a million years do what
she just did I had this whole other
appreciation for what a woman is it's
like a it blows your mama you got kids
and then Patrice is fucking up they're
just big fat black guys saying horseshit
cuz he he's fuckin but it's a funniest
shit on the planet yeah the absolute
funny shit on the planet and you can
laugh at it you don't think it matter I
don't agree with half the shit eat most
of the shit that he says all that
fucking and I looked it I'm an idiot I
don't look at why don't I don't go after
women that are below me I like to go
after women that are above me and that
sort of elevate me and make me want to
be better I think that's it's a little
check and balance system I have him for
myself you know but you don't have to be
so connected to whatever the message is
you can literally take it for face value
which is it's just really funny like
undeniably funny yeah he was a monster
and he also he had points really good
psychological insight he knew what made
people tick
he knew what made people say stupid shit
I knew what made people stumble he's a
who's a master at understanding like how
to
off controversial ideas you know you
know he was and but his his contribution
for a lot of us was uh and he had an
extra level of I don't give a fuck you
know like you'd see done roasts he you
know he Droste and he was like you I
don't even know why I'm up here he only
the one even on my level yeah it was a
Charlie Sheen yes yeah Charlie Sheen
rose again he just went off-script
through the paper he's just that wasn't
murdered he's a killer and he only did
that one because he I guess he agreed
because he said that was the only guy
that he was interested in roasting like
I'm not doing it for the Paycheck
Charlie Sheen's a fuckin G yeah well
it's just that he's you know he would he
just had this don't give a fuck style
yeah and we all like we all I think I
could be speaking for myself I
appreciate I don't give a fuck style
more than any other style of comedy for
me my favorite shit was like first of
all Joey Diaz but then that when you go
back to the greats like Kinnison and
Hicks and this guy's didn't give a fuck
yeah they went out they went off and it
was the most fun to watch as a person
who was an audience member for me was
the most fun to watch Hydra and I think
you know that's that's the shit that
it's yeah we grew up on that and then
society changes and I'm like no dude
I've been I've been working on this for
so long
please let me I have to change my entire
like foundation of what I think is funny
now because and it's almost and that's
why I think guys like Legion a skank
sand the special you guys name it Legion
skanks me and big J okay so big J would
constantly cheat on his wife and it was
like a regular occurrence and she knew
it and everyone know it and one time we
were there and then we were hanging out
and we were about to leave they were in
our argument she's like fuck you
why don't you go hang out with your
Legion of skanks and me and big J we
were both playing guitar hero at the
time there was like a big game we both
looked at each other real like Guitar
Hero name and that was what we named our
band initially in Guitar Hero on was
Legion of skanks and then we're not that
creative so we wrote a script how long
ago is this play 10 years ago 10 years
ago 10 years ago the name and then that
was the guitar or a band maybe even more
probably more you actually way more
because it was right when me and big J
became friends and then we were yeah
Legion of skanks is a great name it's
probably
one of the all-time greatest names of
anything right you stop and think about
like bands or television Legion of
skanks that is a great thank you thank
you a great name yeah well I got to give
it a big jack as he recognized it
immediately and then every project we
ever did since then has been named Lee
Gina skanks until the podcast worked
good move